[Music]
and wrong assumptions news oh you
[ __ ] yeah people be assuming
[ __ ] [ __ ] submitted by the baby
well ah was that channel from the baby
yeah yeah baby I cook you open your like
this to the babies okay
from the baby bear dude that's a
horrible precursor for this child this
town's going to be quitting they coming
out will [ __ ] your son to court down the
puppy huh I wish no oh my god that's the
baby is this Bart's mom Danny if you say
no I'm sila Oh fine I'll show you a
video later you never made it mom yet no
oh wait till you meet it she's nuts
she's a yoga master a kung fu
practitioner ordained minister and
priest and a river
feel like I'm a lot of instructor as
well as a mother of orphaned Childre
same the ocean waves she came to the
ocean yeah sometimes best friend she
makes those icky guy look basic she's
dumb is basically an 8 year old girls
got her soccer team disqualified because
officials believed she was a boy ha ha
ha ha ha she looks like a boy or she
killed it so hard that they're like wait
a second how's this goes running circle
running circles around like how close
does she look - Rosie O'Donnell is a
real [ __ ] party this is an 8 year old
girl so she just looks like a little kid
with really short hair so the way that
her hair is cut is typically what you
would see a forties haircut that's what
oh that's funny the funny thing is the
official said you guys are doing
something shady because that's clearly a
point instead of saying
maybe that's just a little girl that
looks like a boy in this weed well does
this little girl have a mustache no
that's a good question if it was a 45
year old man pain a little bit after we
are
I'd be like they're cheating because
they just got David back this the whole
time yeah or if it was like an eight
year old Mexican boy then obviously full
beard on oh that's just like that
Japanese musician you found that where
is the [ __ ] girl school girl oh my
god what was that
nice piece man nice champagne rubber
I'll show you a video but first I wanted
to mention that she is she's killing it
in the soccer game or she's on an
eleven-year-old roster Oh
though she like killing her niece her
niece was the only girl on an all-boy
team and she was the pitcher oh yeah
sure okay that bet doesn't like a boy I
don't please really cute huh
I don't blame I don't blame them I think
she's looking like a little kid with a
boyish our convoy a little boy I think
so cuz I feel like she could easily
listen okay well you're walking down
Spears I didn't what do you think yeah
but what I'm saying is she looks like
I've expressed brain it should look like
the girl and all I'm saying is that it's
the hair that makes it mana to the
[ __ ] neck only nasty little sweaty
dirty little boys not the [ __ ]
obstruction that yeah oh you didn't
shower you're nasty
what shall we redefine a girl recline
didn't shower girls I'm not even I hate
I feel like something that's concerning
that's why I had it I'd like a lot of
ethnicity all of us obsession honor yeah
guys I have a drawer supposed to be
clean
oh shut up I am a boy what the kid kids
at this age they look like I'm trying
you yeah it's the hair that makes them a
boy or girl what they put on which was
my point that's what I was saying is the
hair I think makes her look like a boy
because then if a little boy like five
or six has like long hair they sometimes
do look like a girl with my
that's also pretty and he had beautiful
curly blond hair my she's like I can't
cut it it's so pretty and it'd be like
Oh your daughter so cute she's like it's
a boy don't get offended lovely with a
girl she is playing with his Barbie so
yeah so here I'm going to show you guys
a video clip of this whole ordeal so you
can hear million Japanese I have a
question yeah is she the only latina on
an all-white team I'm not sure because
then that explains why she's killing it
on the soccer field I don't think so
because the name of the team is like a
Latin sounding team the Bermuda Tigers
Tigers you being focused at a local
mobile like crazy because in a different
articles October oh very poquito pero
locos it's her team is called Omaha
Azzurri cachorros gross oh that sounds
lying as well oh yeah is it Chiquito
adorable no I'm trying to make that
judgmental what is small how do you say
small thank you for Kiko oh that's all
of asking was just the word small to
keep that Chiquito oh it depends how
you're using it yes okay thank you I've
gotta learn Spanish to get off end it
okay here we go
okay he's calling house
so what Oh baby I don't know calling you
of all people out buddy
I'm not getting offended guys I don't
get pleasure okay relax okay here we go
she's threat Millie Hernandez is eight
years old she loves soccer and she loves
her short haircut when my hair said girl
I let this place her because I always
had short hair she's so good even though
she's on the 11-year old rust removers
creature girls be more proud what you
like was the only one I would say bucket
this weekend Corrigan lead her team to
the final but on Sunday before taking
the field nil
and her team were suddenly disqualified
Springfield soccer organizers believed
Milly was a boy Millie's family for our
two tournament organizers to prove she's
a girl it wasn't enough yeah there what
happened to you
no honest so what do they wanted to pull
her pass on yeah no it is it's probably
the opposing team or the [ __ ] league
or somebody hating in that [ __ ] because
when I was in soccer as a little kid
there was this girl that was really
strong and she would kick so hard it
would go right through my [ __ ] shin
guards and that [ __ ] was a [ __ ] and
she was good she was oh she was a
[ __ ] giant playing on a co-ed team
well it's kids so everybody has plays
yeah I mean so it was like it was kind
of like a after school but it was like
one of those recreational activities or
just everybody played with each other so
this [ __ ] [ __ ] was huge and she
would always kick - my [ __ ] son guy
in huge - no could you imagine how big
how big she was for me to call her huge
okay that's a big [ __ ] I remember and
third grade she all of it I had to do
there's no way she could have been
bigger the mission with an older when I
was on Thursday I play soccer too and
then I would always just walk on the
field until the girl that I liked got
the ball so I picked on a garter and
then hopefully like crashing turn a fall
on the ground and roll around your
perfect is the beginning of all the
weird roll he's reverting awesome I'll
just [ __ ] pervert god damn it I love
your own home I like a rocker pervert
Idol I thought you wanted a song doctor
an asthma locker
asmath Ole Miss soccer and as medomak
says it don't care breathe Stephanie
read about all I need take your key
[ __ ] perv oh dude that's ice all I
can think of is have you ever seen her
maybe she's the man yeah when she just
when she dresses up and then she's not
Amanda Bynes
yeah before she went crazy it's all I
can think I was like why didn't I just
like flush yourself I mean she conscious
what Jezebel or then Jackie so what you
know like that's ontology term
jack
Jack yeah like a senior I'm pants down
ma the phrase for them really Polly oh
they do it so much that there's actual
place for it oh yeah I guess you could
walk around so I slap yourself in the
[ __ ] look know if it was the brother
saying that they even had a doctors
physical forms all shown very nice earth
and they refuse to see it
no denied ridiculous it's got to be some
[ __ ] they're hating politics
it's [ __ ] complaining as parents from
the other team that's like there's
something going on to the conspiracy or
maybe like the rest kid is in the other
team
yeah like there's some sort of politics
really this is a [ __ ] kids game like
what is there to gain I'll be single
sperm did you have a fist fight reason
area
I always show such a video of parents on
a soccer field fist fighting if you're
gonna get a goal there's no dinner
can't wait to fight parents who want to
make sure our kids do [ __ ] so that's a
[ __ ] other data no dude you should put
them in all kinds of sports to do
they're such rare occurrences don't do
it for parents to fight like that really
at that Comi no excuse like looking
forward to it we put our kids don't
looking outward rubber boy we put on a
ballet this is mine almost are [ __ ]
up all the ballet PES yeah no I don't
like your [ __ ] kids courtesy don't
every tight me loser what are some
ballerina terms I like a drink no one
yeah tippy-toe tippy-toe cartridge with
all the of meanness I did been away for
a little bit and then I wanted some more
but my mom didn't take me back why all
you were hello a few years had made
Toshi something what how old were you I
stopped when I was about to be done
the reason I was worse a little but
anyways these organizers are saying that
it wasn't due to her appearance all
right horse
I clearly prejudge - yes so they're
claiming that there was a typo on the
roster that said that she was a boy
which is against all the rules there's a
[ __ ] insurance card okay so they
won't comment override that exactly but
they won't comment on that other thing
is that in the future we'll make sure
that these these misunderstandings don't
happen to be real doesn't answer now are
they back on the scene that's I'm going
to find out they're acting like this is
the Olympics and it's kind of like so
official they have to go through so much
red tape and committee organizations
they're like it's all ready to do is
[ __ ] and say oh yeah we [ __ ] up it's a
kid's League bring up bring her back in
whoops sorry yeah through even a
prominent soccer players named Mia Hamm
and Amy Wambach gathered huge yeah so I
know who they are yeah so they both you
know they both gave their support to
Milly like for example uh Amy wrote here
Milly Hernandez you were amazing in
every way think of coaching us how to be
brave and shining a light on something
so hurtful
if you don't know she is my new hero her
team was disqualified from the attorney
because they thought that she was a boy
because of a clerical error that wasn't
handled properly let's meet student
sister cool who's the one that took off
her shirt and we do I don't know I don't
want to soccer you to learn your hand
but what I'm doing I don't know they
should see like my hang yes okay then
that was probably her she let her
boobies hang well she had a sports bra
she's pretty flat-chested so so what he
should do that she was ecstatic
oh she's out a victory yet I think it
was maybe guys soccer players do that
all the time
they do but I think now because it was
kind of a little more sexualized that
they were liable dissection what like
what why would she do a female athletes
haven't done that very much you've never
done yeah I want to see this like a golf
course dude
ah ripped a polo shirt Volken okay you
know every sport so old and it's so like
that's like the class it'll change that
things always flip up though you don't I
don't know you eat nothing master club
or sometimes you see them throw it don't
you see those [ __ ] tennis players
when they get pissed off I saw I saw
Andre Agassi break his racquet on his
foot he was so angry he went oh they
just [ __ ] said why is all I don't
know I thought it was probably looking
up but my brother played tennis and I
used to watch tennis with them because
when we were at the store that's what
you'd like to watch so I just saw he was
walking was angry he goes oh nobody
breaks on his foot like this part guys
yeah very great greatest player that did
that we like school you know they have
the bag that's like multiple tennis
rackets and he got one out and smashed
it and then took the other one out and
smashed it and it holds a lot high
master because he was losing by so much
or like a thousand yeah their customer
or them that's some rock star [ __ ] I'm
so angry hope you guys enjoyed that
video but if you didn't guess what you
can directly contribute to the articles
that we discussed just cruise on over to
the description box below click on that
link to submit your article also for the
next video click right up
[Music]
the